I think it would be really cool to one
day have a contemporary Conjuring movie
I think there's an interesting story
there with Tony and Judy being in charge
for the first time with Lorraine having
passed away the year before and having
to rise to the occasion facing one of
the most powerful demons in Conjuring
lore all in the shadow of the hysteria
that was the year 2020 but could we see
another curious guest set this
Commonwealth can9 free once again if
they ever did something like this it
stands to reason that malus could set
free the other spirits in the room again
and I would personally like to see them
focus on the other evil entities instead
of the three that were already featured
and Annabelle comes home but it would be
cool if the black shuck made a quick
Easter egg appearance but again I don't
think that means that they can't make
that movie especially considering that
most of this franchise is just based on
exaggerated and sometimes madeup stories
as I alluded to there are a lot of
conjuring antagonists whose stories
deserve a closer look